j'accueille dick rivers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est quand même la seule émission
au monde où les rendre et de luxe man et
dick rivers côte à côte
bah je sais pas si vous avez fait à vos
cheveux il y en a ils sont tous blancs
vous ils sont tous noirs
c'est marrant ça bah oui mais il
pourrait y avoir des cheveux un peu plus
noir aussi si bien si vous voulez c'est
ce qu'on lui dit toujours ne veux pas
mais ça lui va très bien ça lui va bien
ce sens look bien que formulée vous êtes
plutôt années 50 comme coiffure évite
aux années 60 voile voilà absolument
années 2000 bien alors dick rivers
bonsoir bonsoir
dick rivers se dit à nos amis et
spectateurs c'est à dire la [ __ ] des
rivières
oui quand il dit que c'est la [ __ ]
rivers
c'est à dire je je vais vous dire une
chose si quand j'ai commencé à chanter
quand j'ai choisi ce nom quand j'avais
15 ans ouais si on m'avait dit que ça
voulait dire ça je rentre il ce prénom
la mort donc je veux dire un mot nazi
c'est quelque chose qui est venu
beaucoup plus tard ouais c'est une sorte
de popol voilà ce que génial génial avec
qui vous avez toujours la banane voilà
ça fait plaisir un apprenant en faites
vous appeler comme ça à cause d'un
personnage interprété par elvis presley
dans loving you exactement voilà ci
s'appelait dick d eux qu à eux et qu'ils
se prononcent dic mais on a lancé ça
aurait fait des quais hudak
mais la big seddik dei ces cas comme vos
voilà mais je répète c'est popol et
réunion en tout cas vous êtes un
personnage harry votre personnage a
complètement bouffé finalement ce que
vous êtes
on croit que vous dormez dans un jukebox
que que que j'écris en voiture amérique
voilà que vous nourrissez uniquement de
hamburgers c'est vrai oui les gens
s'imaginent ça alors que vous avez une
smart et vous vivez à toulouse je ne vis
pas à toulouse je vis à paris mais j'ai
une maison à côté de tous voilà ouais et
alors par exemple on croit toujours
d'être pote avec géniale idée dit
mitchell
vous avez deux voisins ses parades on se
connaît visite est vive
i j'ai toujours une guéguerre entre les
deux r non depuis 40 ans balaie à
l'époque de chats sauvages des choses
est justement et iam la presse crie ça
dure quand même vous dites il vieillit
et comme s'il était le seul et johnny
vous dites c'est devenu un 14 juillet
non je disais que ces spectacles sont
absolument faramineux quoi jaurès et
c'est un petit peu comme les rolling
stones c'est à dire les rolling stones
maintenant c'est quand même le plus
grand groupe de rock encore assistant
mais je vire les spectacles des stands
c'est quand même on y va avant tout pour
le spectacle et je pense que jojo c'est
pareil manquez pas d'air quand même vous
avez déclaré dans france soir en 2005
pour les uns je suis culte pour les
autres je suis branché
oui il ya un autre tiers que tu as
oublié colère mais c'est pas ça c'est
que je touche à peu près plus de deux
générations dont la rue il ya chacun
1,55 juge
voyez ce que je veux vous êtes a pu
tellement longtemps que je me dis soit
culte soient branchés voilà pour
certains c'est date ados trip la légende
et puis pour d'autres c'est branché
parce que on est toujours branché pour
quelqu'un gré 1
on est toujours le branché de quelques
sûrement sûrement alors pourtant quand
même c'est pas si simple parce que vous
dites drucker ça se passe pas bien
quadri qui arrive vous ignorent ça se
passe pas bien et michel oui c'est un
faux gentil m'invite jamais j'ai jamais
regardé une émission de michel le
dimanche et lui
batum a ignoré disons depuis 300 ans et
demi depuis qui fait l'après midi avant
je faisais à l'époque de champs elysées
je fais des émissions est pourquoi je
vous invite pas je sais pas cet état
oublier serge qui te dit tu es trop
branché pauvre du caire
dans ce nouvel album il ya des chansons
de niro comme celle-là des chansons de
mickey 3d de benjamin biolay francis
cabrel and she did we mathieu mathieu
boogaerts peter kingsbery qu'est ce qui
vous a pris on a fait des cpe jeunes
comment te donne vite ça ressemble en
rien à ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à
maintenant
non parce que je fais mon vrai métier
qui t'a mis cela peut marcher
j'espère mais ça a toujours bien marré
dl je touche pas le j'ai pas de problème
de ce côté-là maison que j'ai fait sans
drucker en plus bravo c'est ça sert à
rendre au caire et j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à dix on a à faire mon métier
est un métier d'interprète aujourd'hui à
beaucoup d'auteurs compositeurs
interprètes et moi mon métier c'est de
chanter et je pense qu'il ya eu une
véritable osmose c'est à dire un une
complicité un véritable amour de la
musique et de respect mutuel entre ses
aplombs ça cette jeune génération et moi
alors hervé forneri c'est votre vrai nom
oui vous êtes né à nice en 1945 comme
vous chers amis et voilà votre père
avait une boucherie exactement comme le
père de denise fabre
c'est marrant comme les fils de boucher
niçois ont bien réussi il y en avait un
autre s'il y avait
toubon way dont le père était dans je
crois assez grasse elle était aussi dans
la bouche
alors à la fin des années 50 vous
découvrez les mots magiques coca cola
rock'n'roll blue jeans grâce à la
présence de la flotte américaine dans la
rade de villefranche
mais c'est vrai que souvent le recadrage
est arrivée en france par des gens qui
habitaient près des bases amérique mais
comme bashung c'était dans l'est de la
france
gérard depardieu à châteauroux est
absolument donc vous c'est ça qui nous a
mis en contact avec l'amérique oui moi
aussi loin de ma mémoire remonte jeudi à
l'âge de sept ans qu'on sortait de
l'école y avait des dmp des amériques
des américains qui nous donnaient des
chewing gum des trucs comme ça et puis
plus tard il me donnait des cigarettes
quand on était adolescent bon et puis
c'est vrai qu'avec mes parents quand
j'étais petit j'allais souvent visité
les porte-avions dans la ville de main
franche et donc j'aime manger du
pop-corn j'aime manger des hot dogs
avant le reste des français quoi vous
décidez devenir chanteur quand vous
écoutez pour la première fois un titre
des 10 presse les fameux à brec'h hôtel
way est un blues d'ailleurs guespin
europe
voilà vous dites si elvis n'avait pas
existé l'europe n'en serait pas là c'est
lui qui a fait passer cette musique de
noirs chez les blancs elvis c'est jésus
oui si on sûr c'est une image si on part
en part du principe que dans la crèche
n'est pas l'alcool
si on part du principe que le
rock'n'roll on peut considérer ça comme
une religion à ce moment là elvis
devient jésus le fils de dieu ce qui
fait passer cette musique de un côté un
petit peu obscur au sens propre et au
sens figuré
chez les blancs donc je veux dire lennon
que j'ai très bien connu disait
exactement la même chose j'en ai bien
sûr je suis copain avec paul mccartney
j'ai connu jimi hendrix quand il était
il est arrivé
non c'est vrai mais bien sûr ils
habitaient deux ans et g 16 jeunes ne
croient pas bon ben je crois pas mais
pourtant
ouais mais allons-y qui vous connaissez
les ai connus lennon mccartney marcel
amont jimi hendrix janis joplin que j'ai
connu à londres j'étais très ami avec
brian johns et rolling stone je suis
très ami avec bill wyman toujours et que
je vais voir un concert chaque fois
qu'il vient à paris
je sais pas moi parce que j'ai connu à
elvis mais aussi en 69 à las vegas
sais pas mais ça va écouter dans des
sketches et un peu vous arrêter là on
est on est absolument skol ces listes
ont même connu non à non je suis trop
jeune non j'ai même que je connais
georges locas votre fille était avec lui
pendant trois ans widgets pour ça que
l'année dernière j'ai été invité à
l'aller ces pratiques les gosses
personnes et même connu georges w bush
quand il était gouverneur de texas voilà
enfin bon là l'histoire c'est que dont
vous découvrez grâce aux aux bateaux
ancrés dans la rade de villefranche
la mairie vous découvrez le vice
président est jésus oui et à l'âge de 14
ans vous montez sur scène pour la
première fois avec votre cousin d'aidé
voilà pour jouer quoi allez vous dire
comment vous savez ça on avait fait une
chanson qui s'appelait louis billon big
n d'elvis on avait fait guère next door
est d'aider qu'est-ce qui est devenu
président des états unis je crois qu'il
travaille à l'urssaf panis aulas la
province les fonctionnaires titre est
petit
alors qu'est-ce qui pensèrent les femmes
et rit du début du parcours de dick
rivers
mais comme tout le monde il est déçu non
il
il aime bien c'est les critiques ouais
forneri de des frais il lui pardonne
rien
arrêt et il pense quoi hervé forneri
quand ils voient l'amérique aujourd'hui
par rapport à l'image qui se faisait à
l'époque c'est plus du tout ça non il
est très déçu et hervé forneri il aime
bien
il aime bien une partie du texas austin
notamment qui est une ville absolument
extraordinaire le montana wyoming des
endroits qui sont un petit peu comme me
l'avait dans son subconscient quand il
était petit quoi penser que le rêve
américain s'est effondrée le 11
septembre parce que d'un seul coup
devant les américains sont plus un
refuge son plein soutien
c'est pas que ça je trouve que les
américains se sont énormément les
américains bien pensants enfin ceux qui
sont dans les grandes villes se sont
énormément européaniser et que nous on
sait malheureusement énormément
américanisé dont il ya plus de rêve
je veux dire ça ça paraît bête mais moi
je n'aurais jamais pu penser qu'un jour
il y aurait des mcdo à tous les coins de
rue à paris en province etc
je veux dire quelque part vous en
parliez tout à l'heure mais le hamburger
faisait partie du rêve américain
moi quand j'ai mangé mon premier
hamburger en 1965 à new york avec
marilyn avec l'arrivée
enfin bon reste les playmates ça c'est
un truc fait toujours partie du rêve
vous présenter sur paris première
une émission on voit toutes les filles
de playboy les plaies email
alors faut le dire tout de suite il n'y
a pas de pas de pinet pas de penne 1
c'est un nom c'est cool total et
pourquoi pas à présenter des pornos
quand on s'appelle la [ __ ] dans la
rivière on peut y aller quand même il
faut jeter à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
je le vois je m'amuse beaucoup à faire
ce truc là mais je ne crois pas que
j'irai jusqu'au port no way en 2001 dans
l'événement du jeudi vous aviez de
tester le viagra et vous aviez dit que
vous n'avez pas besoin non seulement je
n'ai pas besoin ça je vous rassure ça va
très très bien tu te fais pas un mec
comme a besoin moi c'est non le viagra
on se demande comment ils ont vent
d'autan finalement ça dépend des
partenaires
ouais à la croix que le viagra et
surtout fait quand après les moches doit
y avoir une loi dmos une lassitude des
partenaires non moi j'avais raconté
il avait fait un test avec des tas de
gens il y avait il y avait une à guy à
montbard maintenant levé laurent ruquier
qu'avait c'est là j'étais endormi
ah oui si vous avez fait de réserver par
sabine alors dit que vous êtes vraiment
la star du rock en france ont offert une
interview fausse modestie bien plus que
vous n'allez pas chez drucker je crois
que cette interview vous fera plaisir
dick rivers est ce qu'on peut dire que
vous êtes le dernier des grands rockers
oui vos textes sont vraiment des bijoux
d'humour d'écriture c'est quoi votre
secret bien m'entourer way savoir
m'entourer de gens qui écrivent
merveilleusement bien pour mettre leur
talent au service de ma voix somptueuse
vous êtes sans doute l'un des meilleurs
chanteurs de votre génération des
chanteurs comme vous il y en a pas
beaucoup qui peuvent se succéder
je vois pas de sucre
je pense qu'on écoutera ma musique
encore dans des centaines d'années vous
avez effectué un parcours sans faute dit
qu'une carrière impeccable qu'est ce que
vous pourriez faire d'encore plus fort
aujourd'hui
or peut-être un film sur ma vie où je
jouerai mon propre
[Applaudissements]
vous avez conscience de ce charisme
animal qui émane de bouddhique
oui d'ailleurs ça me pose souvent des
problèmes parce que les animaux
notamment avec les animaux mais des fois
quand je me promène dans la rue je vois
tous ces gens se ruaient vers moi
surtout c'est une merveilleuse je ne
résiste
vous êtes incroyablement sexy c'est vrai
comment vous résister aux sollicitations
féminine dick
je mets un slip en béton pas pas plus de
40 ans de carrière des cancers à guichet
fermé une centaine de disques d'or de
victoires de la musique c'est mérité
ah oui oui puis je trouve quelque part
certains j'aurais dû mériter par exemple
les les music awards d'énergie je n'ai
pas eu à me un truc qui est marrant
c'est par choix vous avez refusé de
faire une grande carrière internationale
pour loin de chez lui voilà
baffie ouais c'est ça follow me non pas
denise de la france d'or la france donc
j'ai jamais allée voulu aller plus loin
que le québec pays que j'adore
honnêtement sans vous l'industrie du
disque en france seraient dans la merde
non avec c'est ce que me dit hemayma
maison de reims lui heureusement que tu
es là parce que c'est pas avec les
autres artistes que on arriverait à
faire notre beurre parce que vous pensez
qu'on vous mérite vraiment ce soir
écoutez je me suis adapté pour venir
mais je me suis dit bon ma fille est
sympathique je le connais
puis bon thierry ardisson unis soit
comme moi donc c'est un peu un pays qui
n'aime voir nos cerveaux nique
merci d'être là les cadets
[Musique]
elle a fait sien
de toi car
[Musique]
carte ophtalmo vous devez lire les
lettres écrites au mur aulas alors je
vois à partir de jean pull michel
drucker bravo aux x ph bzd nl they have
vr au hsc imaginer gens qui zappe
maintenant non je vois très bien sauf
les deux des deux premières lignes de
là-haut et voudrait un peu moins mais ça
va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]